hi everyone welcome to this next episode
of your daily equation and today I'm
going to take on one of the most
important equations in quantum mechanics
it's known as Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle which indeed means that the
star of today's episode is this fellow
right here not this fella but rather
this guy this is Werner Heisenberg and
he was one of the one of the primary
architects in building the the edifice
of quantum mechanics back in the 20s and
30s you know alongside keep it like
Schroedinger and and and Max Born and
Niels Bohr I mean he Heisenberg made
some of the most profound contributions
and and the equation that bears his name
this Heisenberg uncertainty principle
really marks a very sharp break from the
classical perspective because Heisenberg
shows us that there are qualities of the
world that that we thought were real or
at least we thought that we could gain
access to or at least we thought that we
could measure that we can't that that's
a remnant of an old classical
perspective which Heisenberg basically
blows out of the water with the
uncertainty principle now here's here's
one way of explaining the uncertainty
principle it's a way that I used in
describing the uncertainty principle to
one of the great string theorists of our
age sheldon cooper let me get out of the
way here wait'll you hear how in dumbs
down Werner Heisenberg for the crowd you
may actually believe you're in a comedy
club think about Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle much like the
special order menu that you find in
certain Chinese restaurant where you
have dishes in column a and other dishes
in column B and if you order the first
dish in column a you can't order the
corresponding dish in column B that's
sort of like the uncertainty principle
but oh boom look you know but ump ump is
a perfectly fine response to that kind
of loose description of the uncertainty
principle but I should point out that in
that episode of The Big Bang Theory I
was in scripted they let me say what I
wanted to say within reason of course
and the point I was making there is
actually one that is relevant to the
discussions that were having here
because when you talk about the
uncertainty principle many people focus
upon one particular example the
uncertainty in position and momentum
position and speed and I am in the
discussion today I'm going to focus on
that particular case too but the point I
was making in that little episode there
is that Heisenberg's result is actually
much more general Heisenberg shows us
that qualities of the world really can
be partitioned into two columns like
that like that special order menu and
then the Chinese restaurant then e and
he shows us that knowledge of one
element on one list one quality of the
world in one list can fundamentally
compromise your ability to know a
corresponding quality of the world from
the second list so the point is position
and momenta one example on that long
list so in essence what Heisenberg does
is he says he takes the classical
qualities of the world that we thought
to be real he divides them up and
basically says you can only know half of
those qualities at any given moment in
time so it's a very general result but
as I said I'm going to use position and
momentum as the primary example as we
don't want to be too abstract in these
discussions let me bring my iPad
on the screen good all right so what are
we talking about here
we are talking about the uncertainty
principle and to get into the subject
with a little more precision than I was
able to muster in the Big Bang Theory
episode I'm going to remind you of one
essential quality of quantum mechanics I
discussed it in a previous episode many
of you who have seen it elsewhere if you
haven't seen it before you can look at
offer look at that episode but the point
is this in quantum mechanics we learned
that the momentum of a particle is
directly related to the wavelength of
the corresponding probability with the
corresponding wave function and that
relationship looks like you take
Planck's constant which is this tiny
number 10 to the minus 34 in
conventional units kilogram meters per
second you take that tiny number you
divide it by the wavelength of the
probability wave and that gives you the
momentum or equivalently of course I can
write this as the wavelength is given by
H divided by the momentum and this is a
really important formula for us here
because as I'll show in just a second
this is actually enough to at least
catch the gist to get the gist of why
there would be a trade-off between being
able to specify the momentum of a
particle and being able to specify its
position and and to show you that let me
just bring up an example right up on the
screen here so here's a picture of a
wave and has this nice regular pattern
this nice regular shape and immediately
you can read off the wavelength of that
way if it's nothing but the distance
between one peak and another so if I
were then to to say to you hey can you
tell me the momentum of
particle corresponding to that quantum
mechanical wave you'd say sure well you
would simply do is you'd measure the
wavelength and you'd say here is the
momentum it's just H divided by that
number that you measured H divided by
lambda good but then if I turn to you
with a different challenge and I say
tell me where that particle is located
now you save yourself well in quantum
mechanics a particle can be located at
any position for which there is a
nonzero probability a nonzero value of
the probability wave and there are so
many locations where it therefore can be
based upon this wave shape that might
extend you know maybe across the entire
universe with that wavy shape just
repeating over and over again so where
is the particle located you can't tell
me there are just too many possibilities
there isn't a single answer to give for
that particular probability wave shape
so you can tell me the momentum but you
can't tell me the position if you wanted
a wave shape for what you could tell me
the position you'd want to wave shape
more like this a wave shape that has
more of a spiked shape to it because now
if I say to you where is the particle
located you'd say hey it's located at
that dot over there that dot is located
right under the peak of the probability
wave and in fact I can't really draw it
you wouldn't be able to see it but
imagine I take that that spiked
probability wave shape and I make it
narrower and narrower so it's more and
more concentrated over that dot then
you're telling me that the particle is
located at that dot becomes an ever
better description of the particle
because all of the probability for where
the particle could be is solely
concentrated above that dot but then
come back to you with a different
challenge the flipside of the challenge
that I asked you in the first example
now I say to you hey good you've told me
where the particle is located now tell
me the particles momentum and for that
you say well
you know for the momentum I just need to
identify the wavelength of the wave then
you look at the wave shape and you're
like what's the wave length of that
particular wave shape it doesn't repeat
there isn't a a peak and a peak and you
measure the distance between them in
that particular shape so in this case
you're at a loss because there isn't a
wave length or at least an obvious
wavelength to identify and since
momentum wave lengths are directly
related to each other you can't tell me
about the momentum so in this wave shape
you're able to tell me about the
position but you can't tell me about the
momentum so this little picture kind of
summarizes the basic idea there's this
trade-off you can tell me about momentum
but not position in the first wave shape
you can tell me about position but not
momentum in the second wave shape you
can only tell me about one but not the
other in in essence what Heisenberg does
is he quantifies this idea that I'm
describing in loose language and also
describes it in more general
circumstances where it's not that you
can specify one but not the other maybe
you can sort of specify each to a
certain degree of accuracy but not 100%
accuracy in either position or momentum
so let me show you the formula that
Heisenberg my iPad back up what does he
say so here is the formula that he gives
he defines something called the
uncertainty in position and I will
define what this means precise in just a
moment for the time being just think
about it as some measure of the spread
of possible locations where the particle
might be found and he similarly defines
an uncertainty in momentum which again
you can think about as the spread of
possible momenta that a given particle
might have according to quantum
mechanics and he says that if you were
to multiply those two uncertainties
together it is always greater than equal
to a particular number what is that
particular number it's H Planck's
constant divided by 4pi or if I define H
bar to be H
over 2pi it's greater than h-bar over 2
that is the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle in the particular case
applying it to position and momenta and
you can immediately see what what this
formula is telling us in the classical
world you think that you should be able
to specify the position of a particle
and I really should emphasize the
position of a particle which means you
believe that you should be able to
specify it in such a way that the
uncertainty in position is zero you tell
me where that particle is similarly in a
classical world you think you should be
able to specify the momentum of a
particle that is no uncertainty in the
value of the momentum of the particle
but immediately you see that this
classical expectation would ensure that
Delta x times Delta P equals to zero and
that is certainly not greater than or
equal to H bar over 2 I mean H bar is a
small number but it's bigger than 0
which means according to Heisenberg this
kind of situation which is really the
the heart and soul of the classical
description of the world where you tell
me where things are and you tell me what
speeds they have Heisenberg tells us
that that vision of the world is
incorrect that it runs afoul of this
inequality that he is able to derive
mathematically now in order to put some
flexion on this I need to give you a
clearer definition of what I really mean
by uncertainty in position what I mean
by uncertainty and momentum and then
I'll try to give you very briefly some
deeper understanding of why it is given
those definitions of uncertainty their
products will always be nonzero bigger
than or equal to in fact h-bar over 2
okay so let me begin this fleshing out
then by talking about Delta X
uncertainty in position how do you
define that and for anyone who's taken a
course in statistics or data analysis
what I'm about to say is totally old hat
all it is is the standard deviation
among the possible positions the
possible values of the variable and the
more general statistical language that
in this case the position variable can
take on so let me just quickly flesh
that out so let's imagine we have the
situation over here where we have a wave
function I'm not going to really
distinguish between the probability wave
in the norm square those are important
details physically but to get the basic
idea I don't want to get bogged down in
details so imagine this is the
probability wave and what is that
probability wave telling us it's telling
us the protocol could be here or here or
here or here at any of these locations
and the probability of it being at any
of those spots is given in terms of the
value of the wave function of the
probability wave so if I call this x1 x2
blahblah xn it's actually continuous but
let me talk in the discrete language to
keep things simple then you've got the
probability of being at position X is
given by P I which is the norm squared
of the wave function at that location
and therefore if you wanted to define
for instance the average value of the
position and anybody from this physical
point of view it knows where I'm going
here you consider the sum of P I times X
I and then if you want to get a sense of
how spread out these values are you can
define in this same way the standard
deviation of the values that we see here
and the way you define that is you take
the square root of you take the average
value not of x but of x squared minus
the average value of x squared or if you
like better you can also write this as
the square root of take X
- the average value of X square that and
take the average value so those are the
same but the one above is the one that
I'm going to use however you want to
think about it this gives you the spread
in position and the spread is indeed
what we mean by the uncertainties so
Delta X is defined by this expression
and again it depends on the wave
function because P I is equal to the
norm squared of the wave function at
location X I okay good we've now defined
the uncertainty in the position of a
particle with a given probability wave
how would we play the same game for the
uncertainty in the momentum and indeed
you can play the same game with one
additional fact that I need to tell you
which is in addition to this guy that
probability wave that gets a lot of air
time and talking about quantum mechanics
there is another probability wave and
I'm gonna give it the name
sy hat of P for reasons that will become
clear in a moment and sy head of P does
four momenta what sy of X does for
position namely gives you the
probability that the particle has a
given value of the momentum which really
means I can now draw some axes here
where now that horizontal axis is
momentum not position and I can draw
some kind of wave shape of this sort and
these are possible values of the
momentum and the height of the wave and
this is now sy hat of P that we are
plotting the size of the wave there
gives the probability that the particle
has a certain value of the momentum and
so
sigh hat of P squared is the probability
that the particle has saved this
particular give it a p0 this particular
value of the momentum and with that in
place we can now rerun exactly the same
definition for the uncertainty and
momenta that we did for the that we did
for position we can now do it for
momentum so Delta P therefore is just
the square root of the average value of
the momentum squared minus device let me
do it the way I did it above put the
square inside we gotta give this so
average value P squared minus the
average value of P squared so now we
have a nice definition that gives us the
spread of the possible locations in
position space and we have this guy over
here which gives us the spread of the
possible values in momentum space and
what Heisenberg is able to prove is that
when you multiply those together it's
always greater than or equal to H bar
over 2 now to get there to motivate that
result so we now sort of understand what
this guy is what this guy is I now need
to give you some understanding where
this part of the story comes and I want
to write it for you fully by any means
but I'd like to give you a feel for it
and to give you a feel for it I now need
to give you one more piece of insightful
information which is that we have over
here the wave function in position space
we have over here another object that I
could call the wave function in momentum
space and the fact of the matter is that
Cybex and psy hat of p are not
independent functions in fact if you
give me the wave function in position
space there is an algorithm to work out
the probability distribution of the
momenta and if you give me the
probability distribution of momenta
there's an inverse algorithm to figure
out the probability
distribution of the positions and in
fact the algorithm is very tightly
related to something we also discussed
earlier called Fourier series or Fourier
transform is actually the version of
that that comes into play here and it
will take me too far afield to give you
a full summary or discussion of the
algorithm in the general case but I
would like to at least write it down in
an irrelevant not irrelevant in a
relevant special case which is a case in
which you're dealing with functions that
are symmetric about the origin so called
even function will just make our life a
little bit easier as we write down the
relationship between sy and sy hats so
let me do that so let's imagine that the
probability wave is an even function
centered about the origin and then the
idea is you can write down sy of X as
being equal to and I'm going to write it
in the general form with an integral but
an integral is nothing but a fancy
version of summation where you're
summing over continuous variables so if
you don't like integrals just think
about this as a as a sum if it makes it
easier to think about it and the idea
here is we can write this in terms of
something called it is the same guys
before sine of p times cosine of px DP
DP means we're summing over the possible
p values so so what is this expression
that we are doing here that relates sy
of x + sy hat of P it looks like a
Fourier series because we're summing
together a lot of different cosines and
we're allowing the value of P to vary so
these cosine waves in here have various
wavelengths so as the value you know
yeah that was really badly drawn so let
me try to make it a little bit more
regular so
like this and so forth and even some of
them that might look like this the
different thighs of pee correspond to
the different waveforms as P varies P is
dictating the wavelength of the cosine
function and this guy over here in the
Fourier language this guy is giving the
weight the weight of each contribution
so it tells you for a given value of the
momentum a given value therefore of the
wave length how much of that wave is
within the function the wave function
side of X so when you think about this
way it makes perfectly good sense that
this guy over here is giving you the
probability of the particle having that
momentum because it's in this expansion
saying how much of this wave is within
the original wave function and the wave
length here indeed is dictated by the
momentum according to the rules of
quantum mechanics so it's telling you
how much of that particular value of the
momentum is inside this wave function
and you can similarly write down the
reverse of this you can write down side
hat of P you can write that in terms of
size X so this is the algorithm going
the other direction integral from minus
infinity to infinity sigh of x times say
cosine of PX but now integrated with
respect to X so this is the algorithm to
go say from Cybex to sy hat of p and
this one allows you to go from Sun Hat
of P to side of X and this relationship
this Fourier transform relationship
allows us to see why it is that the
better you say understand the position
the less you can understand about the
momentum and vice versa and to show that
I'm going to give you one concrete
example to wrap this up
let's imagine that we're looking at a
wavefunction sigh of X that say it's e
to the minus a X squared so that is a
wave that looks like this and the
question is what does sigh hat of P look
like for that choice and this is just a
calculation in calculus it's just
sticking this particular function into
this particular formula to work out
what's I head of P is and I'm gonna give
you the answer it's not obvious but it's
a beautiful answer the answer and again
I'm not giving all the factors of pies
and twos and things this is just
schematic the answer is e to the minus P
squared divided by a and that's
fantastically interesting why because a
here controls the width of this Gaussian
form of the example of this probability
wave so when a say is really big then
this wave will be very narrow because
Chinese of X would give you a large
negative exponent which will take you
deep along the tail and when a is very
small X needs to go pretty far out to
get the exponential drop off so the wave
gets ever more wide but notice that the
a appears upstairs here and it appears
downstairs here which means when a is
such that this wave is wide the
corresponding wave if I draw it over
here for psy of piece I had of P this
guy will be narrow when this guy is why
because the a is in the different spot
and vice versa which means that the
better you know position the less you
know momenta and vice-versa let me show
that to you is I have a nice little
version of that I can bring up on the
screen here so here
are to wave shapes notice if I squeeze
down the wave shape in position space
allowing me to have a better
understanding of where the particle is
located I am minimizing I am decreasing
the uncertainty in position what I do
that the uncertainty in the momentum
widens now I can do the reverse
let me now squeeze down the uncertainty
in momentum by making the momentum wave
shape more narrow I'm going to do that
look what happens to the wave upstairs
it widens out
I can't squeeze them both down
simultaneously because they stand in
this Fourier transform relationship and
that relationship ensures that when one
is now or the other is why in fact I can
squeeze it down even further in momentum
space to really nail down the momentum
make Delta P the uncertainty in momentum
really small and look what happens the
wave in position space just stretches
out even more giving me more and more
uncertainty in the position and bringing
back my iPad ensuring that Delta x times
Delta P indeed is greater than or equal
to H bar over 2 so I haven't done the
numerical part of it but you see how
squeezing down 1 ensures that this guy
goes oh maybe I can even do that with
arrows a little better so if I make this
one over here go down so I am getting
better understanding of where the
particle is the uncertainty in the
momentum goes up whereas if I allow this
one to go down so I better understand
the momentum of the particle then the
uncertainty in the position goes up all
ensuring that their product is bigger
than or equal to H bar over 2 so let me
finish up with just a couple quick
remarks here number one this
relationship between a wave and its
fourier transform in the language that
I'm using it's a mathematical result it
was known in the 1800s it was known by
people who were undertaking analysis
since
no processing they weren't talking about
quantum mechanical wave functions they
were talking about sound waves and they
were finding that if a sound wave is is
very sharply peaked say in terms of when
it happens then the frequencies are very
broad so you can say when the sound was
you understand that it's very sharply
peaked in time very broad in frequency
but the reverse could also be true if
it's very sharp in frequency then the
wave form goes on for a very long time
and therefore you can't say when that
sound happened and therefore you have
this trade off and it was a trade off
that was known in signal processing and
so the quantum mechanical uncertainty
principle at Heisenberg found is kind of
a rediscovery or perhaps a better way of
saying it it's up it's a reapplication
of an idea that was known in the 1800's
but now not applied to sound waves say
but apply to probability waves and in
that guise it gives you the quantum
mechanical uncertainty principle final
point that I'll make well let me make
one other quick one because some people
always say to me I'm gonna try to do it
this time they say hey can you put some
numbers into some of the formula that we
have and let me just do that so you can
get a feel for the size of this I wrote
some of these down so imagine we have a
baseball right and imagine that baseball
is going whatever you know around 50
meters per second and it has a mass
equal to the the standard mass if you
look it up on the major league baseball
website and imagine that I measure its
momentum to within one part one hundred
so I do a reasonable job
I know its momentum within say one
percent of its value what would that
mean for the uncertainty in the position
well you can just plug in the numbers to
the Heisenberg formula and if you do
that you will find that the uncertainty
in position is about 10 to the minus 34
meters 10 to the minus 34 meters that's
tiny on the scale of a baseball and
that's why we don't know about the
uncertainty principle in everyday life
you can pretty much best
the momentum and the position of a
baseball within the accuracy of any
measuring device that we have okay now I
should say you know applying this to a
baseball is a little tongue-in-cheek a
baseball not a single particle it's not
described by a single wave function so
imagine that we have a single particle
with the mass of a baseball and the
properties that I just described you
would be able to talk about its position
and its momenta within a level of
accuracy that's well beyond anything
that we measure typically in everyday
life or even with fantastically precise
equipment but what if you now play the
same game not with a baseball but with
an electron right now an electron
imagine again that you measure its
momentum to within one part in ten to
the two but now again momentum is mass
times velocity the mass of an electron
is so tiny that the value of Delta P
even with this level of uncertainty is
pretty small which means when you plug
in to Heisenberg's formula Delta x times
Delta P greater than or equal to H bar
over 2 of Delta P is really tiny Delta X
has to be bigger how much bigger
well Delta X it turns out is about ten
to the minus eight meters not gargantuan
but 10 to the eighth meters that's like
atomic scales electrons live at the
atomic scale so on the scale that's
relevant to electrons this uncertainty
is a big deal you really can't specify
where an electron is and what its
momentum is in a manner that won't
violate Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle because the numbers involved
are so tiny that the value of h bar
being small doesn't save you
right so uncertainty reigns in the
microscopic world even though in the
macroscopic world you can pretty much
ignore it okay that's why we don't know
about the uncertainty principle in
everyday life final final point the more
of a philosophical point and for that I
need to take a small sip of water which
is this what actually is the uncertainty
principle telling us right is it telling
us that particles don't
have position and momenta or is it
telling us that we can't measure
position in momenta cuz sometimes you'll
see descriptions of the uncertainty
principle framed in terms of the
following people say hey when you try to
measure the position of saying an
electron you have to bounce something
off of it some light off of it so you
can see it and it's that disturbance to
the position and momentum of the
particle that prevents you from knowing
where it is and how fast it's moving at
the same time it's the disturbance view
of uncertainty and look I've used that
language too it's not awful to think
about it that way but it's very limiting
the answer key principle is woven more
firmly into our understanding of reality
than having to do with this disturbance
picture right so in the conventional
approach to quantum mechanics the idea
would be that the very notion of having
position and momentum simultaneously
runs afoul of the quantum mechanical
formalism so it's in that way a
description of the qualities of reality
rather than the qualities of reality
that we can measure now having said that
let me just finish up with the following
point that conclusion depends on the
precise version of quantum mechanics
that you are committed to there are
versions of quantum mechanics that are
sort of maybe a dark-horse approach to
quantum mechanics the one I have in mind
is the so-called dubrow Bohm Theory
David Bowie David Bohm and Prince Louie
DeVry and in this version which people
don't really pay much attention to it
makes the same predictions at standard
quantum mechanics but in that formalism
a particle like an electron does have a
definite position and it does have a
definite momentum it's just that the
quantum equations are unable in
principle to access those qualities
they're only able to access them in a
statistical manner that has uncertainty
built in from the get-go so in this
formalism
particles would have definite positions
and definite momentum that would be the
ontology to real rock-bottom qualities
of reality even though quantum mechanics
and perhaps our ability to leverage
whatever measuring equipment we could
ever write down we'll never be able to
access those qualities of the world so
you might say well in the end what
difference does it matter and I'd say as
far as predictions go it doesn't matter
but as far as your view of what reality
is what's really out there in the world
it does make a difference do particles
have positions and momenta but we just
can't get at them or do they simply not
have positions and momenta
simultaneously and our classical view of
the world is simply wrong so it's a it's
an open question most physicists have
the latter perspective but I simply
point out that the former perspective
has not been ruled out and indeed
there's a theory that realizes that very
possibility okay a bit of a long episode
but I hope you enjoyed the details and
and this this exploration of this key
equation of quantum mechanics the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle Delta X
Delta P greater than equal to H bar over
2 that is your equation for today that
is your daily equation take care until
next time see you then